hallo
guten Abend guten Abend guten Abend wie schön
erinnert ihr euch daran wie Beatrix von Storch
auf der Maus abgerutscht ist Maus gerutscht wisst
ihr das noch erinnert ihr euch daran wie Donald
Trump vorgeschlagen hat sich Desinfektionsmittel
gegen Corona zu spritzen oder daran wie Horst
Seehofer sich darüber gefreut hat dass an seinem
69 Geburtstag 69 Flüchtlinge nach Afghanistan
abgeschoben wurden das ist das Niveau auf dem
die Mächtigen dieser Welt über die dringenden
Probleme unserer Zeit sprechen das ist das Niveau
das heißt wir müssen darüber reden wie wir über
die Welt reden die Welt ist voller Katastrophen
und voller Probleme aber jedes einzelne dieser
Probleme bis auf den Tod und bis auf die Liebe
darin werden wir für immer verzweifeln aber jedes
andere einzelne Problem auf der Welt wäre lösbar
wenn wir ihm mit ehrlicher Vernunft begegnen
würden was wir mit beeindruckender
Konsequenz nicht tun und deshalb ja
deshalb müssen wir nicht einfach alle Themen
abarbeiten nicht einfach jedes Problem lösen
sondern wir müssen den Populismus bekämpfen und
zwar mit allem was wir haben und ich habe dafür
ich habe dafür bei allem Pazifismus die härteste
schärfste mächtigste Waffe mitgebracht die ich
besitze ich habe Gedichte geschrieben so
und ich möchte anfangen thematisch mit dem
Protesten im Iran das habt ihr bestimmt alle
mitbekommen oder diese wahnsinnige Revolution
diese feministische Revolution die da abgeht
im Iran diese komplett verrückt mutigen Frauen
und Männer die alles riskieren um um sich zu
erheben gegen dieses Regime und ich finde es
ganz interessant wie das hierzulande diskutiert
wird zu großen Teil nämlich einfach gar nicht
aber es gibt auch eine gewisse Gemeinsamkeit
zwischen den Parteien so alles von den Linken
bis zur FDP wie Sie darauf reagieren
SPD Parteivorstand hatte z.B auf Twitter
geschrieben die sozialdemokratischen Frauen
Europas stehen solidarisch an der Seite der
Frauen im Iran womit nuripur einer der beiden
Vorsitzenden der Grünen an alle Frauen im Iran
der Ukraine in Afghanistan oder in Sau di Arabien
wir stehen an eurer Seite Katja leikert von der
CDU ich bin mir ganz sicher dass wir alle
hier fest an der Seite der Frauen im Iran
stehen Ria Schröder von der FDP Freiheit ist
weiblich wir stehen an der Seite der mutigen
Frauen im Iran das fand ich ganz interessant
und das hat mich zu folgendem Gedicht inspiriert
liebe Frauen im Iran ich stehe nicht an eurer
Seite selbst auch Teile ich eure Wut wer das
sagt verkennt die Weite die uns trennt in Raum und
Mut ich bin hier und ihr seid da was euch trifft
das trifft mich nicht weder Kugel noch gefahren
noch das Herz das in euch bricht ich sehe euch nur
digital auf Bildern Spende euch Applaus vielleicht
weine ich sogar mal doch dann bin ich wieder raus
an der Seite einer Heldin ja so sehr auch ich mich
gern doch zwischen mir und euch sind Welten und
ihr seid die die sie durchqueren ich stehe nicht
an eurer Seite ich stehe hinter euch und staune
und ich sehe wie ihr leidet ich steh hinter euch
ich raune und ich flüster was von Zeit um euch
als Echo beizustehen ich stehe hinter euch ganz
weit in eurem Schatten kaum zu sehen vielen Dank
es geht
es gibt einen Mann der sich auch an dieser
Formulierung gestört hat das ist ein Mann ist
ein Journalist das ich bin ein großer Fan von ihm
es ist glaube ich einer der wenigen Journalisten
über den man wirklich völlig ohne Einschränkung
sagen kann das ist ein guter Journalist das ist
so einer von denen die wirklich gewissenhaft
arbeiten die objektiv sind aber zugleich so eine
gewisse Empathie der Welt gegenüber mitbringen
Julian reichelt hat folgendes dazu gesagt
Julian reichelt hat tatsächlich geschafft
diesen diesen Satz noch schlimmer zu machen
er hat gesagt Merksatz für alle die jetzt
fest an der Seite der Frauen im Iran und
Afghanistan stehen je mehr junge Männer
aus diesen islamischen Diktaturen zu uns
kommen desto mehr wird unser
Land wie Iran und Afghanistan
Herr Reichelt ich weiß Sie sind für Feminismus
wie ein Stein einst für die Physik ein Vorreiter
ihr Altruismus ist unerreicht und unbesiegt
ich spreche glaube ich hier für alle sie sind
unser frauenschild OB Muslime Mutter Christin ob
Praktikantin bei der Bild ich möchte einfach Danke
sagen für ihre Kraft wo ich vertrage und ich würde
mich nie beklagen ich habe nur eine logikfrage
der Mensch ist ja im allgemeinen recht bequem und
faul im Kern sie kennen das von sich beim Denken
der Mensch verlässt sein Heim nicht gern wer also
von zu Hause flieht ist das nun echt der Islamist
wer ins Unbekannte zieht ist das nicht der der
anders ist der keinen Krieg will und kein Leid
den man verfolgt dem Strafe droht der in Gefahr
ist sich befreit von Gefängnis Folter Tod ich
könnte sagen mir egal Frauen Männer Kinder
viel sind ein Gewinn für dieses Land solange
sie nicht so sind wie sie doch heute geht es mal
nicht um Hetzer ja auch das sollte man nicht mal
geben es geht und sorry für das Pathos es
geht um Frauen Freiheit leben vielen Dank
das habe ich noch
eins habe ich noch dann ist die Lyrik Lesung
für heute auch beendet aber eins habe ich noch
von einem anderen Mann der ist keine Journalist
aber trotzdem eines meiner großen Vorbilder ist
gar nicht lange her Friedrich Merz hat nämlich in
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch daran bei Markus Lanz
Anfang Januar gesagt als es um diese Diskussion
ist es um die silvesterausschreitungen in Berlin
ging äh hat er gesagt wir sprechen hier über
Leute die eigentlich in Deutschland nichts zu
suchen haben sprechen Sie mal mit Lehrerinnen
und Lehrern in den Grundschulen was die jeden
Tag erleben auch an verbaler Gewalt und dann
wollen Sie diese Kinder zur Ordnung rufen und
die Folge ist dass die Väter in den Schulen
erscheinen und sich das verbitten insbesondere
wenn es sich um Lehrerinnen handelt dass sie
ihre Söhne die kleinen Paschas zurechtweisen
Herr März ich weiß Sie sind
für Feminismus wie ein Stein
einst für die Physik was hat Rassismus
dass er selbst sie zum Gendern kriegt
lieben sie Rassismus mehr als sie den Feminismus
hassen oder spült er seit jeher mehr Wählerstimmen
in die Kassen klar Migrantenkindern Rinnen die
Privilegien aus dem Schlund die mächtigen sind
Grundschulkinder mit Migration im Hintergrund
nicht etwa weiße oberschichtler juristensöhne
Millionäre die wahren patriarchatsgesicht da
der Quell der weiblichen Misere sind kleine
Paschas und ihr Vater die ruchlos Lehrerinnen
quälen dazwischen sie als adäquater Frauenheld
ich würde sie wählen meine echt sie machen
alles richtig sie sind nun mal ein starker
Mann der ist und das zu sehen ist wichtig mit
Grundschulkindern aufnehmen kann vielen Dank
das war super oder das war richtig gut
das war richtig Spaß gemacht euch auch
oder seid ihr bis zum Ende geblieben also
es wird ja gefallen haben vertraut er mir
jetzt ne das ist gut das möchte ich jetzt
direkt nutzen euer Vertrauen abonniert das
mal bitte hier das ist keine versteckten Kosten
einfach abonnieren gibt keine Zusatzkosten und
dann wäre gut wenn ihr das anguckt das Video
und das dann auch das sind beide supervideos
die ich nicht kenne aber die sind bestimmt
super da mal bitte draufklicken weil es hat
euch ja jetzt gerade gut gefallen und dann wäre
schön wenn er da auch mal was zurückgeben danke